Quand tu sors d'une émission de télé-réalité, tu as 2 possibilités de carrière qui s'ouvrent à toi.
Soit 1. Tu tombes dans l'oubli, et Senna de Secret Story a choisi l'option 2.
C'est à dire sortir un single.
Avant de tomber dans l'oubli.
La musique s'appelle "Clap your hands"
et c'est quand même une des vidéos qui a le plus de votes sur Youtube...
de votes négatifs, pardon, au temps pour moi. C'est pas rien.
Et voilà, Senna, très connu pour son talent de... hum... de... présence, se met à chanter.
*chanson* "Everybody in the party clap your hands. All my ladies, all my fellows clap your hands."
Senna, numéro 1 de la voix la plus trafiquée devant Colonel Reyel et Tragédie.
Oui je sais tout le monde a oublié Tragédie. C'est normal, ça s'appelle la mémoire sélective.
Et le clip, c'est du grand art. Le mec porte quand même une casquette des Yankees de New York à Miami.
Aaah Marseille, quelle fabuleuse ville pour tourner un clip dommage qu'il fasse un petit peu froid, hein.
*cri de mouette*
Pourquoi vous pointez un fusil vers moi, monsieur?
*Bruit de rechargement*
Je crois que le monteur du clip a complètement abusé... de tous les plans qu'ils ont tourné...
ils ont gardé ça quand même.
De toutes les expressions du visage,
je crois que c'est bien celle-ci qui se rapproche le plus de la **** de ***, on est d'accord.
Sans les bip c'est "la tête de con", hein.
Même chose, quelqu'un qui se prend un coup de casquette dans le nez,
tu gardes pas ce plan au montage.
Ça choque que moi, sérieux?
Et surtout, j'ai fait une grande découverte sur cette musique, écoutez la mélodie.
Et maintenant on garde les mêmes notes, et on les déplace.
Ils ont utilisé les mêmes notes que La Danse des Canards.
*chanson*
Tout est dit.
Voilà, vous pouvez retrouver toutes mes autres vidéos sur Cyprien.fr
et si vous aimez cette musique autant que moi,
vous pouvez partager cette vidéo sur votre mur Facebook et rejoindre ma page.
Si vous ne le faites pas,  je vous oblige à écouter la musique de Senna pendant 15 minutes.
Ahhh on fait moins les malins maintenant, hein!